Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Okay. Business situation, today's Hook.
A Hook is a good conversation piece that you can use with people when you're talking.
Today's Hook is about the culture of debating.
Western people really like to debate.
In the order of debate, you have to say something that you disagree with somebody.
So, a lot of times, Western people when they're talking, they'll disagree with you...
...or they'll be the devil's advocate, and they'll say the opposite that they're thinking.
Japanese people tend to get hurt during this situation and they get offended,...
...but Western people, it's really good that each person is giving them input and new ideas.
So, don't get insulted, it's just part of a culture.
And the more ideas, the better something gets, so please let people debate,...
...and debating is a very healthy thing.
So, in that kind of situation, the Native Menu.
That's food for thought.
It's an eye opener.
Wow! That's an eye opener.
Oh, wow! It's an eye opener.
Okay. And Maestro Lines.
Maybe we should go with plan B, not A.
Oh, wow! You know what, that's food for thought.
Yeah! I'm gonna go think about it, that one.
Thanks a lot!
You know, how about doing it the opposite way?
Oh, wow! You know what, that's an eye opener.
I couldn't have thought of that.
Thank you!
Alright, thanks a lot!
And business English, there's always more good stuff in AERA English's Native Maestro.
So, see you next week and have fun speaking English.
Bye-bye!